PAUL SAXMAN: Hello everybody.
Welcome to this week's Google
Maps developers office hours
or Google Maps Developers
Lives.
I'm Paul Saxman and--
MANO MARKS: I'm Mano Marks.
PAUL SAXMAN: And this week--
yep, Mano you don't need an
introduction because we were
just talking about you
are the face of maps.
But in any event, so this week
we're going to just rattle
through a bunch of updates this
week, or actually that
happened over the
last few weeks.
There's been a lot of things
going on in the Google Maps
Developers world.
And we just want to make sure
that you guys are well aware
of everything that's
been going on.
Just to kick things off and get
going, very first thing is
the More than a Map.
Last week we talked about
it at the Google
Maps Developers Live.
Luke and Chris were here to
give a talk about the
technology behind it.
If you haven't seen the site,
it has a lot of great
information for developers.
Particularly, if you go
to the site you can
see quite a few demos.
Now we have demos of
a lot of the core
features of the Maps API.
Including things like Satellite
Imagery, Street
View, the routing of places,
and data visualization.
Each of these has a really
nice feature set
that you can go over.
In this case, in Places API,
you can see searching in
different locations.
You can search on different
types of information.
Everything is centered around
a certain geographic area.
So I don't think this
demo does it.
But switching my search
type I can find--
this one does still
say centered--
but restaurants, lodging.
The Places API has quite a few
different place types.
Other samples that we have in
here, other demos that we have
in here, we can go over
to satellite imagery.
Really, really interesting
site, if you
haven't seen it already.
The cool thing that Luke and
Chris talked about last week,
if you weren't there, was that
this actually uses one map for
actually all of these demos.
So that's a really nice tid
bit for developers to know
about, because you can actually
reproduce the same
thing instead of re-loading the
map every time somebody
accesses the page.
You can actually keep it running
in JavaScript in the
background.
MANO MARKS: They don't want us
to tell you this, but that
reduces your map loads.
MANO MARKS: Oh yeah,
that's the implicit
benefit of all that.
So in addition to the demos,
be sure to check out the
developer stories.
These are actually pretty
inspiring stories.
I'm not going to run any of them
now, but they're really
good stories about developers
using the Maps products and
doing things benefiting their
community, and what they think
about the APIs.
So the site is morethanamap.com,
if you
haven't seen it yet.
Next up we have--
actually I'm going to
go off my tabs--
the Google Places API
Developer Challenge.
Just today, actually,
we updated the
timeframe for the challenge.
We've actually gotten quite a
few good submissions so far,
and I think--
well, actually I didn't
mention it
last week at the GDL.
But yeah, we've gotten quite a
few good submissions but we're
looking to actually collect
a few more.
Some of the feedback we got from
developers was that they
just need a little
bit more time.
So the new time frame is
November 30th for getting the
applications submitted.
And the voting is actually
bumped into December.
So December 12th through
the 31st is going to
be the public voting.
We will have a website
up for the public to
actually use to vote.
The important part about this,
as a developer, if you're
submitting something to
the challenge you
need a YouTube video.
So be sure to put a quick
YouTube video together and get
your submissions in.
Voting by the judges continues
through the first of the year,
or January 11th.
And then the winners will be
announced at the end of
January next year.
So if you're not familiar with
the challenge, I think we
talked about it last week and
a couple weeks before.
But check out the
developers at
google.com/places/challenge.
All the links, More than a Map,
Places Challenge, all the
other stuff we're going to talk
about today we'll put
them in the comments in
the YouTube stream.
So don't worry about
writing them down.
Next up, couple events
coming up this week--
actually, this upcoming
weekend.
Actually, me and Brendan
Kenny are going to be
at the DevFest West.
And that's this Saturday and
Sunday at, actually, the
Google Campus.
If you want to attend, it
appears that there's still
quite a few tickets available,
six tickets.
They're $5 a piece.
Seems like a pretty good deal
to come hang out with us on
the weekend.
Brendan and I are going to be
talking about big data and
Google Map.
So how do you get large amounts
of data on a map.
Specifically that's going to
be talking about heat maps,
symbols, and canvas layer,
which is a library that
Brendan and Mano have
been working on.
We had a GDL a few
weeks ago talking
about the canvas layer.
It's a really cool technology
for using WebGL
on top off a map.
And Mano, you're going
to be someplace else?
MANO MARKS: I'm going to be
at DevFest Silicon Valley.
Which will be Friday
and Saturday.
I'll be there on Friday.
I think they're still updating
their schedule.
That's more of a hackathon
focused DevFest.
I'll be talking about basically
the same stuff.
I think I titled it differently,
like the new
advanced features
of the Maps API.
But it's basically the
visualization and canvas
layer, heat map, symbols
that sort of stuff.
So that kind of stuff I think is
really exciting, and really
makes Maps API in the browser
just so much more useful.
If you can get to DevFest
Silicon Valley, I will be
there on Friday.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, so there's
registration right here, big
green button.
And looks like it's--
MANO MARKS: Looks like
there's still spots.
PAUL SAXMAN: Still slots
available, so yeah.
So Brendan and I are
on Saturday.
I think it's at 10:30 AM
at the DevFest West.
And you're going to be talking
on Friday at--
MANO MARKS: I think it's
going to be 2 o'clock.
PAUL SAXMAN: 2 o'clock, cool.
All right, moving on.
What do we have next?
Google Developers Academy.
MANO MARKS: So Google Developers
Academy launched
right around I/O this year.
And we now have four courses in
Google Developers Academy
for Google Maps.
We haven't really done any
big announcements about
this up until now.
So we're pretty excited
to show that off.
There is a course on getting
started with the
Google Places API.
One on customizing Google Maps,
changing the color,
styles, marker, customer
markers, that sort of thing.
We have one on importing data.
So essentially how to use JSONP
and XML HTTP requests to
bring in your own data.
Some very basic JavaScript
stuff, but really essential
for people who are learning both
JavaScript and the Maps
API at the same time.
Which is a pretty
common thing.
And then finally, there's one on
the visualization using the
symbols and heat maps that
we've been talking about.
So these are some
great courses.
We'll put links up to
them in the comments
on the YouTube video.
And yeah, so check these out.
These are kind of unknown.
We haven't gotten very many
hits, because we haven't done
any advertising yet.
But they're up and ready
for you to go on.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, and as Mano
mentioned, actually I did the
Google Places one before
I was actually on the
Google Places team.
That was around I/O time.
Actually, I got a lot of
questions when I was joining
the team about using the auto
complete service with the
Android application.
So we do have an Android
sample in there.
And really another interesting
thing, so
the visualizing data.
If you can't make it to one of
the talks that we mentioned
earlier that's going on this
weekend, you probably want to
check this out.
Because there's going to be
a little bit of overlap.
But definitely if you can make
the talks, we'd definitely
love to have you there.
And actually these other ones,
I should probably read a
couple of these.
I'd probably learn
a thing or two.
So moving on.
So yeah.
So the other thing--
I think it was two GDLs ago--
we talked about some updates
to the Google Places API.
Specifically, we have
query auto complete.
So Query Autocomplete, it's an
autocomplete service like the
pre-existing autocomplete
service where you
provide an input box.
And as the user types into the
input box, the service
actually will display up to
five autocomplete results.
And the existing autocomplete
API returned only addresses.
Or actually, you could
specify types.
So you could return addresses,
places, or the like.
The new service actually, the
Query Autocomplete, this is an
extension beyond the
existing service.
It actually includes search
terms as well, or query terms.
Let me zoom this guy
in a little bit.
So a classic example that we
always have is pizza, because
a lot of people search
on pizza.
So you can see here
that we have--
actually this is just
a query term.
So pizza is the query term.
We actually have places
returned.
And actually it looks like these
are also terms as well.
So we interweave popular query
terms with popular places so
you can put these in an
autocomplete box.
The results, actually, that you
get back from the service
is a list of places.
So these are places that matched
the key word pizza, as
opposed to matching a
particular place.
So it looks like here we all
have restaurants, but wonder
what's a good search term that
would be both restaurants and,
let's say, grocery stores.
MANO MARKS: Well,
I don't know.
But you are looking in Sydney.
So I don't know if
kangaroo would?
PAUL SAXMAN: No, looks like
they don't have many.
In any event, we'll see if we
can come up with a good demo.
Take a quick peek at the code.
Let me just switch over
to my IDE here.
So the codes are pretty
straightforward.
Just like you the autocomplete
service, you
provide your input box.
So here's where we're actually
getting the input target down
here, the text input.
You actually pass that to the
search box service, or the
search box class or object, and
provide a callback function.
So as the user types this in
the callback functions--
or actually as the user submits
the search, your
callback function is
made or called.
And here you can see we're
just creating markers and
we're placing the markers
on the map.
The interesting thing about this
is it is actually using
the place image.
So the places service returns
images for places.
And that's based on the little
icons we saw earlier.
And it's also positioned
by the geometry
of the place itself.
So pretty straightforward.
I mean, this whole sample that
we saw is 84 lines of code,
including the map code.
The other addition to the Google
Places API that we
released recently was the
autocomplete data service.
So this actually works a lot
like the autocomplete box or
the search box.
Except that you actually get
access to the data before it's
actually rendered into
the input box.
So previously, with the search
box or the autocomplete, is
you just provided a text area
and it does the actual
rendering of the selection
last or the list of
predictions.
Here, you actually
get to render
the predictions yourself.
So if I do, let's say, 1600.
So here you can see this looks
a little bit differently.
That's because this
is actually being
rendered by our code.
And all we did here is we just
highlighted the search term in
the Query Autocomplete
results.
So the nice thing about this is
A, you can actually do what
we're doing here highlighting
the code.
You can actually control
what the prediction
selection looks like.
But B, you can also interweave
your own results.
So if you have information
that you think is more
relevant to what we're
returning, or you want to
actually include that in the
autocomplete results, you can
feel free to do so.
Code for that is, likewise,
pretty straightforward.
I had these backwards.
Data service.
So again, this time you create
the autocomplete service.
And you provide a callback
listener.
And that callback actually gets
the list of predictions.
So the predictions are the list
of places, essentially.
And then you actually
can display
those however you like.
And here, so all we're doing is
we're taking the callback
or the results and we're
highlighting and putting them
in the div to display them.
What else is interesting?
This one the sample is a
little more complex.
I think it just has a
little more styling.
We had to go through all
the styling of the
autocomplete box.
And then also, you have to
control what happens when the
user clicks on the prediction.
But pretty straightforward.
We'll post the links to both
of these samples in the
comments or in the description
for the YouTube video.
And Mano, you're up.
MANO MARKS: So we had
two more launches.
The first one here
is time zones.
So this is a new web service API
that allows you to query
Google servers.
You pass it a UTC timestamp and
a latitude and longitude.
And it returns back to you
information about what the
actual time was at
that location.
So I've got a couple
of links here.
If you click this particular
one, for instance, it shows
you what the offset is
from Standard Time.
So this is Los Angeles
and the raw offset is
in seconds, I guess.
So you just pull that,
divide by 60, and you
get number of minutes.
And then 60 again, you
get number of hours.
So this is a common request.
So that's what it looks
like in JSON.
And then you can also get it
back in XML if you like, if
you prefer that.
You see the information there.
And of course, we also
pass back to you
the time zone names.
So we decided to do this
because we got a lot of
requests for it.
People want to know what
the time zone is at
a particular location.
And it's fairly complex, because
time zones have lots
of different rules,
and they change.
When daylight savings time is,
or whether they even support
daylight savings time, and what
not, and in all sorts of
different ways.
And then there's crazy little
townships that don't support
daylight savings time.
So when things shift, that one
town stays an hour later or
earlier than somewhere else.
So we just keep track
of all that for you.
And like most web services,
it's limited to
2,500 calls a day.
And if you have Maps API
for Business, it's
100,000 calls per day.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's an
interesting point I should
have brought up about the Query
Autocomplete and the
data services is that actually I
think those were a couple of
the top developer requests
that we picked off and
implemented.
So one thing I always think is
always a little curious about
our services is we actually
don't JSONP wrap our results.
MANO MARKS: Right.
PAUL SAXMAN: So what
do you do for that?
Is this also part of the
JavaScript library
for the Maps API?
MANO MARKS: No, I don't
believe time zones is
currently in the JavaScript
library.
It's web services only.
But you can run it server side,
and pull it, and then
send it back.
PAUL SAXMAN: And potentially
also put your own wrapper
around it so you if you want it
in your JavaScript code put
a JSONP call around it.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
So the other thing that
we launched--
and this is for enterprise
customers only--
we added traffic conditions
to driving directions.
So if you take a look here, I
don't know if you can actually
zoom in on the traffic
conditions.
PAUL SAXMAN: You drive.
You drive on our driving
directions.
MANO MARKS: So basically the
section I'm highlighting here
just says about one hour and 22
minutes or one hour and 26
minutes in current traffic.
This sample happens to be in
Australia, so there's not a
lot of traffic there
right now.
But it gives you, based on
current and historical
traffic, estimates.
Whether if we're getting current
traffic conditions or
based on what we know
about that at a
particular time of day.
So it's pretty powerful.
And actually the code for
it is very simple.
The same standard creating a
driving directions, which is
available to everybody for your
enterprise customers.
And then you create a driving
directions service and pass it
a request with a bunch
of options.
And you'll see here, all you
have to do is highlight one
particular option here.
You add in this duration
in traffic true.
And it passes that
back to you.
That's traffic.
And I think that wraps
up our wrapping up,
our round up here.
We're super excited.
If you want to see more of these
things as they're being
launched follow our Google
Geo Developers blog.
And also, we announce things
on our Google+ page.
And usually something goes out
on our Twitter feed as well.
That's all I've got.
PAUL SAXMAN: That's
everything.
So check the description.
We're going to post
all the links.
And if you guys have any
questions, also you can post
in the YouTube comments and
we'll see if we can get back
to you on those.
MANO MARKS: Right, or post
on the Google+ page.
And we'll answer
those as well.
All right.
PAUL SAXMAN: Thanks
for joining.
MANO MARKS: Thanks for joining.